[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJ CHETTY: The American
dream is fading.
Only half of kids today will go on
to earn more than their parents did.
Why has this happened?
And how can we reverse the
fading of the American dream?
When thinking about how
to answer these questions,
you might not think of big
data as a place to look.
Big data is often
associated with corporations
seeking to improve the products
they offer by collecting
troves of data on their customers.
But what if we could use
big data for social good,
to address problems such as the
fading American dream, growing income
inequality, or persistent
racial disparities?
This course will teach you
how to use big data, coupled
with the tools of data
science and economics,
to solve some of the most important
social problems of our time.
So the tools that you're
going to learn in this class
will be applicable not just
to the types of problems
that we'll discuss here in the United
States, but globally around the world.
Big data helps us cut through
politically charged debates
and find out what policies actually
work from a scientific perspective,
making the often discussed notion of
evidence-based policy making a reality.
Big social problems
require big data solutions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]